[Applause]
a bit shorter
well welcome everyone to the 2022 nickel
fellowships and screenwriting Awards and
live table read
as a writer director and producer I'm
being blessed with the opportunity to
help tell Amazing Stories and this
evening I'm joined by an incredible
incredible collection of talent as we
celebrate six new storytellers and their
nickel fellowship-winning screenplays
for the live read portion of our show we
are joined by some immense talents we
have first of all lottery D Collins who
is an actor and producer a former United
States Marine and a passionate advocate
for service members and veterans
lodrick can currently be seen starring
in the highly rated bet drama series The
Oval and he also recently portrayed
music legend Smokey Robinson in mgm's
award-winning Arisa Franklin biopic
respect
so please welcome Roderick D Collins on
the stage with me
now born and raised in Honolulu Hawaii
actor Keiko againa is best known for her
serious regular roles on the show's
prodigal son where she played Dr adrisa
Tanaka and Gilmore Girls where she
played Lane Kim for seven years and
reprized the role in Netflix Gilmore
Girls seasons
so please let's welcome on the stage
Keiko
[Applause]
Monica Barbara can currently be seen
starring alongside Tom Cruise in Top Gun
Maverick Paramount's highly successful
sequel to The Classic 1986 film
next year Barbaro Stars off as a Diego
Veneta in Paramount plazas at midnight
which serves as the banner title of the
streamer's Latin American Originals
production as well as Netflix Global spy
Thriller Fubar opposite Arnold
Schwarzenegger let's please welcome this
to the stage Monica
[Applause]
actor Dorian music will appear in
Netflix surely Amazon Studios the bureau
and the independent feature be real cool
all due for release in 2023 has recent
television work includes Syria's regular
roles on ABC's for life
CBS all access tell me a story and
Netflix's Luke Cage please welcome to
the stage Dorian
[Applause]
great let's begin
so through the power of their stories
the six new nickel fellas Sam Cali
Christopher Timothy JM and Jennifer have
brought us together this evening
and sharing the characters and
conversations
the twists and turns that make their
stories uplifting and inclusive funny
and fantastic surprising challenging
feels vital and important
in just a few minutes we're going to
hear and feel the award-winning stories
of these sexy screenwriters brought to
life by audrico Monica and Dorian and
we'll hear from the new fellows
themselves
celebrating their achievement is both
the culmination of the nickel
fellowships 2022 competition and the
beginning of something amazing for our
new fellows
that's the story being told here tonight
[Music]